[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen Wintersport gibt es
von Norbert Lehmann und einen schönen
guten Abend und wir beginnen mit einem
Blick ins umkämpfte dorflitzerath
Räumungen die Polizei rückt in das
besetzte lützerath vor viele Aktivisten
leisten keinen Widerstand es bleibt
überwiegend friedlich
schwierige Fecht in der Ostukraine
russische und ukrainische Truppen
kämpfen erbittert um die Städte Solidar
und bachmut
und Debatte über Jugendgewalt nach den
Silvester Krawallen will Berlin die
Sozialarbeit für Jugendliche Stärken
aber auch härter durchgreifen
heute morgen hat sie begonnen die
Räumung von Lutzerath durch die Polizei
klimaaktivistinnen und Aktivisten
versuchen das Abbaggern der Braunkohle
unter dem rheinischen Dorf zu verhindern
wenn die abrissbaggerlützerath im Boden
gleich machen bleiben westlich von Köln
fünf kleine Orte erhalten die zum
ursprünglichen Ausstiegsdatum 2038
ebenfalls von der Landkarte verschwinden
sollten sie überleben war das Land
Nordrhein-Westfalen den Kohleausstieg
auf das Jahr 2030 vorgezogen hat über
den ersten Tag der Räumung berichtete
Färber
Feuerwerkskörper gegen die Polizei ganz
friedlich lief der Beginn der
lützeraträumung am Morgen nicht es
sollen Molotow-Cocktails geflogen sein
ein berechtigter Protest findet die
Sprecherin eines Aktionsbündnisses es
gibt unterschiedliche Menschen die in
unterschiedliche Aktionen gehen und es
gibt genug Leute die hier in
Sitzblockaden gehen die die Baumhäuser
besetzen mehrere tausend Polizisten sind
heute im Einsatz die ersten setzen sich
morgens in Bewegung und 350 Menschen
befinden sich da noch auf dem Gelände
die Polizei erwartet viel Widerstand
viele wollen möglichst lang bleiben sie
sitzen auf sogenannten Tripods
Dreibeinern in der Höhe oder haben sich
in den Gebäuden verschanzt ich
appelliere an alle die noch vor Ort sind
schützen Sie das Klima aber schützen sie
mit ihrer Anwesenheit keine
gewaltbereiten
auch sie können jederzeit ohne weitere
polizeiliche Maßnahmen den Ort verlassen
und außerhalb des Geländes friedlich für
die Anliegen demonstrieren das ist unser
Angebot ein großer räumungseinsatz in
Lutzerath der noch lange andauern könnte
das macht nicht nur der Polizei sorgen
sondern auch den im Bund und Land mit
Regierenden Grünen die Kohle unter
lützerath bekommt RWE dafür wird der
Kohleausstieg auf 2030 vorgezogen das
verantworten grüne und erklären
nun glaube ich auch dass Klimaschutz und
protest-
aber der die leergezogene Siedlung
lützerath wo keiner mehr wohnt ist aus
meiner Sicht das falsche Symbol der
Einsatz in lützerath geht weiter und
trotz aller Widerstände kommt die
Polizei dabei bislang schnell voran
und vor Ort ist für uns Ina Baltes Ina
wie ist die Lage jetzt gerade wie
verläuft die Räumung
ja die Räumung ist erstaunlich schnell
verlaufen die Polizei hat ja heute
morgen lutzerat sozusagen gestürmt mit
einer großen Hundertschaft und jetzt ist
mal mittlerweile hier in den hinteren
Teil des Dorfes gekommen wo mehrere
Scheunen stehen vier schäumen und in
diesen Scheunen da haben sich die ähm
Aktivisten verschanzt die haben
Plattform gebildet die von der Decke
irgendwie so fliegende Teppiche nennen
sie in der nicht das mal und da müssen
sie jetzt einzeln runtergeholt werden
und das passiert jetzt man hat schon
eine Scheune gelehrt man ist an der
nächsten dran das ist ein hoher
logistischer Aufwand aber die Polizei
geht sehr präzise sehr schnell vor und
es sind jetzt auch wieder frische
Polizeikräfte gekommen so dass es mir
scheint Bestätigung haben wir nicht aber
es scheint mir so dass das hier noch
länger dauern wird man hat Licht
aufgebaut und ganzen Dorf ist natürlich
kein Strom mehr kein Licht aber man hat
lichtmasken aufgebaut und das bedeutet
dass man hier wahrscheinlich diese
ganzen Scheunen noch räumen will und
dann werden die Aktivisten hier einzeln
rausgetragen und es ist ein Zaun um
lützerath gebaute so dass sie nicht
wiederkommen können und dieser Zaun wird
von RWE bewacht und so wird Stück für
Stück Lutzerath gelehrt aus lützeratina
Baltes danke schön
über die aktuellen Entwicklungen rund um
die Räumung im Braunkohle Revier
informiert Sie unser live-block einfach
reinklicken in die ZDF heute App oder
online auf heute.de
der Krieg in der Ukraine dauert jetzt
schon fast 11 Monate an besonders
umkämpft ist immer noch der Osten des
Landes im don-bas reklamieren auch heute
wieder Russen und Ukraine Gebietsgewinne
für sich ein Stellungskrieg der in den
vergangenen Monaten in der Region
bachmut viele Opfer gefordert hat eine
Schlüsselrolle spielt dabei der kleine
Ort Solidar Franziska von tiesenhausen
berichtet
in Solidar ist jeder Meter hart umkämpft
das Ausmaß der Zerstörung enorm erste
Meldungen die Stadt sei eingenommen
worden dementiert die Ukraine
hier gibt es keine Hysterie keine
Einkesselung keine Ultimaten zu
kapitulieren oder sich in Gefangenschaft
zu begeben
und auch Moskau spricht heute von
anhaltenden Gefechten in Solidar
Luft Landetruppen haben den nördlichen
und südlichen Teil von Solidar blockiert
die Luftwaffe beschießt ukrainische
Stellungen und Bodentruppen kämpfen in
der Stadt
die Einnahme der Stadt wäre ein
wichtiger Schritt für die Eroberung
bachmuts wenige Kilometer südwestlich
dort toben seit Monaten heftige Kämpfe
mit hohen Verlusten auf beiden Seiten
man hat sich so festgebissen weil die
russischen Streitkräfte seit mehr als
fünf Monaten keine Erfolge mehr haben
und auch Mut und Solidar sind halt zwei
Städte wo der Erfolg jetzt so zynisch
das klingt zum Greifen nah liegt und den
man braucht um halt auch innerhalb ich
sag jetzt mal der Truppen und äh in
Russland selber zu zeigen dass dieser
Krieg dann doch nicht nur zur Ungunsten
der Russischen Föderation verläuft über
die strategische Bedeutung von bachmut
sind Experten unterschiedlicher Meinung
auch ob die Eroberung der stadtgrößere
Auswirkungen auf den weiteren
Kriegsverlauf hätte ist umstritten
die Frage die sich aber stellt ist wie
viele der professionellen Soldaten der
Berufssoldaten der ukrainischen Armee
sind dort gefallen die könnten der
Ukraine dann fehlen für die angekündigte
Offensive die im Frühjahr seitens der
Ukraine erfolgen soll ein Berater von
Präsident selenski bezeichnete die
Kämpfe als blutigste des gesamten
Krieges und ein Ende ist noch nicht in
Sicht
und unsere Partner Tim Kröger war heute
in bachmut und der Region unterwegs Tim
welchen Eindruck haben sie von der
militärischen Lage gewonnen
also in dieser Umgebung von bachmut und
Solidar ist der gefechtsheim gegenwärtig
ist dieser Krieg allgegenwärtig es ist
militärisches Gerät auf den Straßen
unterwegs das sind Soldaten unterwegs
und wir haben dort eine ukrainische
Einheit getroffen ungefähr 15 km von der
Front in Solidar entfernt dort wo sie
vor wenigen Tagen noch eingesetzt worden
ist und die Soldaten haben uns erzählt
wie massiv diese Angriffe von russischer
Seite ist und wie viel Kraft es kostet
sich dem entgegenzustellen wir haben uns
von der Kälte erzählt die hier im Moment
herrscht und das ist von dieser Kälte an
der Front praktisch gar keinen innen
drin gibt wir haben uns aber auch
erzählt dass sie dringend mehr schwere
Waffen brauchen für die Verteidigung
dieser Region
Bevölkerung wie ist denn die Situation
der Menschen die noch machen sind
also bachmut wirkt auf den ersten Moment
Menschen der wir waren dann aber doch in
einem Wohnblock wo noch endliche
Menschen aus harren meistens in Kellern
sie haben sich dort Räume eingerichtet
wo sie zu mehreren schlafen aber es
fehlt die natürlich an allem es fehlt
ein Medikamenten es fehlt ein
Lebensmitteln es fehlt ein Wasser
meistens wird das dann nur durch
Hilfsorganisation zur Verfügung gestellt
und die Menschen haben uns erzählt dass
sie aber trotzdem nicht weggehen weil
sie etwa Angehörige nicht alleine lassen
wollen oder ganz einfach weil sie auch
nicht die finanziellen Möglichkeiten
haben um wegzugehen wir haben aber auch
das haben wir uns gesagt weiterhin
Vertrauen in die ukrainische Armee dass
sie wachmund halten kann danke schön Tim
Krüger aus der Ukraine
seit längerem schon fordert die Ukraine
Leopard-Kampfpanzer Polen erhöht jetzt
den Druck insbesondere auf Deutschland
sein Land wolle gemeinsam mit
verbündeten Ländern den Leopard an die
Ukraine liefern erklärte Präsident duda
die Bundesregierung bleibt in dieser
Frage zurückhaltend Berlin spielt in der
Debatte eine Schlüsselrolle weil die
Leopard 2 Panzer in Deutschland
entwickelt wurden dürfen sie nicht ohne
deutsche Genehmigung abgegeben werden
nach Deutschland das ist in der
Silvesternacht in mehreren Städten vor
allem aber in Berlin zu Gewalt gekommen
ist wird von einigen auch aus der
Politik mit einer gescheiterten
Integration erklärt es hieß die 145
Festgenommenen kommen aus 18 Nationen
jetzt aber wird das Bild über Taten und
Täter ein wenig klarer
laut Polizei wurden von den 145 nur 38
wegen Angriffen auf polizei und
Rettungskräfte festgenommen von diesen
38 Personen haben 23 fast zwei Drittel
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft
wieder Gewalt von Jugendlichen also egal
welcher Herkunft begegnet werden kann
darum ging es heute bei einem Gipfel in
Berlin Markus groß berichtet
große Runde am Vormittag im Roten
Rathaus Politiker Sicherheitsexperten
Sozialarbeiter sie alle wollen Antworten
finden auf die silvesterkrawalle und die
Diskussion um Jugendgewalt dass wir
nicht nur jetzt die Aufgabe haben
Maßnahmen der konsequenten
Strafverfolgung der Unterstützung
Ausstattung von Polizei und Justiz
voranzubringen sondern wir haben auch
die Aufgabe und über die tiefergehenden
Probleme die mit diesen Ereignissen der
Silvesternacht verbunden sind
auseinanderzusetzen das Thema ist in
Berliner Wahlkampf angekommen der Gipfel
heute ein reines Wahlkampfmanöver
kritisiert die CDU wir haben in Berlin
mittlerweile Milieus die wir ganz
offenkundig nicht mehr erreichen wo
junge Leute abgehangen sind wo sich
Gewaltexzesse ausbrechen und hier
brauchen wir keine keine neuerlichen
Gesprächskreise sondern wir brauchen
endlich Taten ein gießkaffee im
Neuköllner Brennpunkt hier versuchen
vorwiegend türkischstämmige Mütter die
Geschehnisse der Silvesternacht
aufzuarbeiten die Antworten vielfältig
dass die schon eine Strafe bekommen
sollten es muss kein Gefängnis sein wenn
man die Eltern mit aufs Boot hat die
Elternarbeit Erziehungsarbeit
Bildungsarbeit mit den Eltern durchführt
widerspiegelt sich das bei den Kindern
Morus 14 ein Projekt für Bildung und
Integration die Arbeit zeigt Erfolg
wir bereiten Jugendliche auf
Schulabschlüsse vor gleichzeitig gibt es
eben auch andere Träger die ganz gezielt
Jugendliche die in Kriminalität
abzuleiten drohen irgendwie präventive
ansprechen so dass eben frühzeitig auch
interveniert werden kann Strategien
gegen Jugend Gewalt am 22 Februar will
man sich wieder im Roten Rathaus treffen
dann werden konkrete Ergebnisse erwartet
in der Debatte um die silvesterkrawalle
sein immer wieder rassistische
Ressentiments zu hören kritisiert die
Integrationsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung Riemen aller Bali
Radovan sie legte heute ihren ersten
Lagebericht zu Rassismus in Deutschland
vor und betonte Rassismus sei eine große
Gefahr für die Demokratie ein Bericht
von Winnie Hirscher
wenn zwei Kinder gleich viele Fehler
machen bekommt er mit dem Namen Murat
eine schlechtere Note als der mit dem
Namen Max ein Beispiel für Rassismus in
der Schule wissenschaftlich untersucht
und belegt im Lagebericht den die
Integrationsbeauftragte erstmals
vorliegt
so haben bei der Studie
22% der Bevölkerung ausgesagt dass sie
schon einmal Rassismus erlebt haben und
90 Prozent haben gesagt ja es gibt
Rassismus in unserem Land was will die
Bundesregierung dagegen tun es sollen
mehr unabhängige Beschwerdestellen
eingerichtet werden an die sich jeder
wenden kann die Beratungen
Migrantenorganisation soll ausgebaut
werden
Opfer Initiativen wie zum Beispiel in
Halle oder Hanau gestärkt werden ein
Expertenrat soll definieren woran
Rassismus eigentlich beginnt
kritisch äußert sich die SPD-Politikerin
vor allem gegenüber der Union in Sachen
silvesterkravalle in der ZDF-Sendung
Markus Lanz hatte CDU-Chef März gestern
über Respektlosigkeit von Kindern mit
Migrationshintergrund in der Schule
gesprochen dann wollen Sie diese Kinder
zur Ordnung rufen und die Folge ist dass
die Väter in den Schulen erscheinen und
sich das verbitten insbesondere wenn es
sich um leere Rinnen handelt dass sie
ihre Söhne die kleinen Paschas damals
etwas
zurechtweisen diese Bemerkung führt
rassistische Restaurants ich finde es
sehr erschreckend dass die Union jetzt
diese Debatte so nutzt und Menschen
stigmatisiert das Thema Rassismus wird
auch wegen der anstehenden Berliner
Neuwahlen weiter hat diskutiert
in Ibbenbüren in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat
ein Schüler seine 55-Jährige
Berufsschullehrerin getötet er hatte sie
allein im Klassenzimmer aufgesucht und
dann unvermittelt zugestochen danach
lief die Polizei der 17-Jährige soll
häufiger mit Lehrkräften in Streit
geraten sein direkt vor der Tat hatte er
einen eintägigen Schulverweis erhalten
in den USA hat eine Computer Panne für
massive Einschränkungen im Luftverkehr
gesorgt alle Inlandsflüge wurden für
mehrere Stunden gestoppt grund war der
Ausfall eines wichtigen Systems das
Pilotinnen und Piloten mit
sicherheitsinformation versorgt und über
Störungen im Luftraum informiert fast
1000 Flüge fehlen aus mehr als 6000
waren verspätet warum ist zu der Panne
kam ist noch unklar das Weiße Haus teilt
aber mit es gebe keine Hinweise auf ein
Cyberangriff
seit Monaten wird im Iran gegen das
Regime protestiert auch heute wieder es
geht um Freiheit aber auch um die
schlechte wirtschaftliche Lage die EU
hat auch wegen des harten Vorgehens des
Regimes gegen die Demonstrierenden
weitere Sanktionen verhängt die Menschen
leiden unter einer hohen Inflation die
Armut wird immer größer aus dem Iran
berichtet Jörg Brase
liefert Lebensmittelgeschäfte und
Supermärkte mit Hühnereiern das Geschäft
sei krisenfest dachte er weit gefehlt
seit der vor sieben Monaten damit anfing
hat sich der Einkaufspreis fast
verdoppelt die Regierung hat die
futtermittelzuschüsse gestrichen jetzt
müssen die Bauern Hühnerfutter im
Ausland einkaufen und weil der dollarkur
so stark gestiegen ist haben die
Produzenten Probleme bekommen damit sind
auch meine Ausgaben geschrieben
oder Ladenbesitzer alle haben weniger
Geld in der Tasche sie alle seien Opfer
einer fatalen Entwicklung meint der
bekannte wirtschaftsjournalistischer
vergangenen Jahren seien die Reichen
trotz Sanktionen noch reicher und die
Armen ärmer geworden
die Schere zwischen den sozialen
Schichten geht immer weiter auseinander
wir haben immer mehr arme Menschen
mittlerweile leben 25 bis 30 Millionen
unter der Armutsgrenze
auch das ein Grund für die Proteste die
gehen weiter so demonstrierten am Montag
einige hundert vor dem Gefängnis nahe
der Stadt gegen die Hinrichtung von zwei
jungen Männern
zwar wurden bisher einige Hinrichtungen
aufgeschoben heute stoppte der Oberste
Gerichtshof das Todesurteil gegen einen
19-Jährigen vorher erst das sei aber
nicht als Einlenken zu werden betonen
Irans Justizbehörden nichts deutet
darauf hin dass sie Rans Führung ihre
Politik der eisernen Faust aufgeben
könnte die ließ heute Anhänger vor der
französischen Botschaft auf marschieren
Protest gegen Karikaturen von Ali
hamelnay in einem Satire Magazin und
Treue Schuhe für ihre ans Revolutionen
Proteste im Iran mehr zur Lage im Land
um viert nach 10 im auslandsjournal
in Bochum hat eine gewaltige Explosion
ein Mehrfamilienhaus zum Einsturz
gebracht die herbeirufene Feuerwehr
konnte nach mehrstündiger suche eine
Frau nur noch tot aus den Trümmern
bergen eine Person wurde leicht verletzt
austretendes Gas in der Nachbarschaft
hatte sich entzündet und zu der
Explosion geführt mittlerweile ist die
Gasleitung wieder abgedichtet
im Beverly Hills wurden wieder die
Golden Globes verliehen mit neuer
jury-besetzung und einem altbekannten
Preisträger Extremist des biomülls der
Brother Berry
ber Regisseur ist Steven Spielberg ist
der große Gewinner des Abends sein
autobiografisch geprägter Film The Fable
mans wurde als bestes Drama
ausgezeichnet und der selbst für die
beste Regie Colin Farrell bekam den
Preis als bester Schauspieler in der
Kategorie Komödie Michelle jo als beste
Darsteller
und jetzt kommen wir zum Wintersport und
zum Nachtslalom und Flachau Norbert da
hat mir die deutschen Skifahrerin
richtig was zu feiern wirklich tolles
Teamergebnis das Beste seit 2010 mit
drei Athletinnen in den Top Ten darunter
Lena Dürr mit ihrem herausragenden
dritten Platz im zweiten Lauf wo sie
sogar die schnellste Zeit
zum zweiten Mal in diesem Weltcup Winter
schafft Lena Dürr damit den Sprung aufs
Podium die Münchnerin im zweiten
Durchgang hellwach auf der
Flutlichtpiste von Flachau vorläufige
Bestzeit die überragende US-Amerikanerin
Michaela shiffrin unterbietet diese
zunächst dann Petra Wüller die Slowakin
noch einmal um 43 100 Sekunden schneller
verhindert damit das Schiff in ihren
rekordan Weltcup Siegen weiter
verbessert Jessica Hilzinger achte mit
wem Norm immer Eicher 9 das
Mannschaftsergebnis der deutschen mit
Lena Dürer als vorzeige Läuferin ist das
Beste im Slalom seit rund 13 Jahren
Auftakt des Biathlon heimweltcups in
Ruhpolding mit einem starken sechsten
Platz von Benedikt doll der 32-Jährige
leistete sich im Einzelrennen beim
Schießen nur einen einzigen Fehler der
kostet den aber einen Podestplatz erster
wurde der Norweger Johannes Tinius der
seine 60 Weltcup-Sieg feierte
ja und den knapp zwei Stunden beginnt
die Handball WM in Polen und Schweden
die deutsche Mannschaft trifft am
Freitag auf Katha letztes Training heute
in Barsinghausen und dann heißt es
Koffer packen das DHB-Team hochmotiviert
ohne die noch aus dem Kader gestrichenen
Lukas Zerbe und dem Zechel absolvierten
heute 16 Spieler das Abschlusstraining
letzte taktische Feinheiten wurden
studiert und die gute Stimmung im Team
muss sogar den sonst eher
zurückhaltenden Trainer Alfred
gießlersson angesteckt haben
Stimmung ist gut also ich denke das die
Masche doch sehr sehr gut mitmacht und
dass wir alle erstmal ein bisschen drauf
brennen endlich mal nach Polen zu
fliegen dies lass uns Team ist der Star
und er führt seine Spieler auf einer
gemeinsamen Linie auf dem Weg zur
Handball Weltmeisterschaft
ja das Spiel Deutschland gegen Katha
live bei uns im ZDF zu sehen am Freitag
ab 17:40 Uhr und wir haben noch die
Lottozahlen für Sie die Gewinnzahlen
lauten 17 21 24 25 32 48 Superzahl ist
die 5 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie
auf lotto.zdf.de und den zdf-text auf
Seite 557
viel Regen und viel Wind begleiten uns
morgen durch den Tag mehr zum Wetter
gleich Katja horneffer das heute journal
können Sie um 21.45 mit Christian
Sievers sehen und Morgen begrüßt Sie
hier Barbara halweg auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend diese Wolken werfen einen
Schatten auf das Land unten drunter hier
in Deutschland aber auch in Frankreich
und in Spanien und dieses scharf
begrenzte Wolkenband ist weiter nach
Osten gezogen und wird abgelöst durch
ein neues Tief das liegt heute Nacht
schon über der Nordsee und zieht im
Laufe der Nacht weiter Richtung Ostsee
bis morgen früh ist dann schon das
nächste Tief da und so regnet es kräftig
zwischen Schleswig-Holstein und dem
Saarland am ehesten trocken ist die
Nacht hier zwischen Berlin Brandenburg
und dem Oberrhein in Südosten zieht noch
Regen ab die Temperaturen dazu singen
heute Nacht auf 8 bis 0 Grad und das
Tief der Nacht zieht dann morgen
wiederum weiter nach Osten und wird
wieder abgelöst durch ein neues Tief das
bis morgen Abend dann wieder
Schleswig-Holstein erreicht haben wird
es fällt also viel Regen so viel Regen
das in Nordrhein-Westfalen in Nordhessen
oder auch in Rheinland-Pfalz einige
kleinere Bäche und Flüsse durchaus über
die Ufer treten kann wir erwarten auch
Orkanböen auf dem Brocken im Harz die
Sonne werden wir kaum als zu Gesicht
bekommen bei Höchsttemperaturen zwischen
7 Grad in der Oberpfalz oder auch am
Alpenrand und 13 Grad am Niederrhein es
geht sehr wechselhaft weiter am Freitag
mit Gewittern am Samstag mit etwas mehr
Sonne im Osten und am Sonntag wird es
etwas kälter tschüss